Film Courage: Would you say starting
a film career at age 35 is too late?
Alok Mishra, Producer: Nope, I don't think so. I
mean I think you can start it when you're like 45
but hopefully you've thought it through hopefully
you have to have it depends what you want to do
right like if if you're a producer well. I mean
look, if you have a good sense of story and you
like to read a lot that's one type of producer
in terms of being creative but do you are you a
people person do you like talking to people do you
like solving problems I mean that's another kind
of producer if you want to direct I mean look I
get that's in a lot of people's hearts but I feel
like there there are a few people that deserve to
direct that have really thought it through I mean
like the technical aspect of like the camera of
where their they they can have the idea and the
passion on the page let's say but some haven't
really thought about how how this is going to
move or that's going to move and they don't have
the wherewithal to hire somebody who's a great
director of photography to help shepherd them
through the process let's say right I think it's
much hard I fear ever if someone I have nightmares
where I have to direct something that's my
nightmare because I just think there's so there's
so much goes on in that whole thing like that
I just know my brain doesn't work that way I but
it's my nightmare like I was if I was ever half to
gun to the gun to head if I did direct something
I'd be like I'm just going to have a panic attack,
I've never had a panic attack in my life, but I
like literally having a dream about this right
now like we're having a nightmare like I think
that there is a certain amount of learning and
skill that goes into certain positions like if
you want to be the art director or the production
designer or somebody like that I think you have
to put in the time I think you probably have to
put in like what is it 10 years before you get
good at something as they say right I think that
those are there certain positions where it may be
harder to start later in life but there are other
things that you could already be very well versed
for if you love reading and you love stories and
you love even editing you could probably start
later in life but you need to probably take a
lot of classes and also be a be a a junior what
is it assistant assistant editor for many years
before you get to the place where you're going to
like be able to be trusted to do that in any big
capacity would you hire a 60-year-old first-time
director I think that's a tough question actually
I mean it depends on I don't know it to me it
depends it depends on the writer director or
because if they're the writer director then maybe
there's something to that because look that's
truly their vision on the page from to to whatever
it is so I mean I feel I feel about better about
hiring writer directors in general than I do about
hiring a director versus and a writer it's like
the same person has to be satisfied which is good
just one person right but going back to question
65-year-old director depend on the person depend
on the project that's what I would say what about
a person 65 or older writing a screenplay for
the first time I mean look there's tons of like
online classes there's tons of things to learn
how to get the format right in terms of like
helping with structure helping you with maybe
actual some of the subject matter there's a lot
of really great first time screenwriters right
I would have no problem with that depending on
how good the script is you there's a lot of
experience screenwriters write a lot of mean
things too by the way so it's like there's no
I would have no problem with it depending on
the person of course cliche question but I just
have to ask it best piece of advice someone gave
you starting out and worst piece of advice you
leave out the names to protect the non-innocent
well going back to the shorts you're making a
short make it short that's that was one good
piece of advice what's what was the worst advice
Rotten Tomatoes doesn't matter I had a publicist
tell me this one time Rotten Tomatoes doesn't
matter and I I got in a yelling match with with
them and I was like are you out of your mind let
me tell you why it matters because when you're
dealing with a movie maybe for horror movies it
doesn't matter cuz it doesn't sometimes it really
doesn't like whatever slasher it doesn't matter
when you have a movie that rides the line between
genres that could be a thriller and it could be
a horror movie right it absolutely does matter
because what's happening in this day and age what
that that this person didn't realize is that the
different streamers are putting that number that
Rotten Tomato certified fresh right next to your
movie when people are scrolling through that
movie that pops up literally in the scrolling
it'll pop up and I can say oh wait that's 88% I
might give that a chance okay why not let's try
it the other thing they do in the streamers is
they put you in subcategories Rotten Tomatoes
accredited is a category critically acclaimed is
a category on Netflix for example this is one more
category you're going to be in when people are
scrolling so they can pick you right that is why
Rotten Tomatoes matters and that's why this person
who will go unnamed of course, it was completely
wrong do you believe things happen when they're
supposed to happen 100%, 100% I mean fate, karma,
whatever you want to say I feel there is what
you put out of the universe that you get back
a lot of times and I feel like if you put the
work in and you put your heart into something
sometimes it won't happen for you but sometimes it
does happen for you and I think that look hard no
no one no one can decry hard work but as long as
you're working smart that's the other thing too
like don't work just don't put your slay your head
against the wall again and again learn from your
mistakes figure out ways to make things work when
they're not working and try to surround yourself
with people who are like-minded people who want
to get stuff done who aren't just like the people
that are like oh we're going to sit around and
look at the sky maybe one day we'll do that no
we're the getting stuff done crew okay and I want
to surround myself with those people and that's
that's going to be our team that's who we want
to work with that's that's what you need to work
with if you want to be serious about this business
do you think that there's a way to tell who those
people are when you first meet them or no it takes
time I think it takes time I think it takes time
you got to see look you meet a guy and he's like
I'm working on the script and 10 years later I'm
working on the script okay great well you keep
working on that script that's cool you know
it's sad to say but like I think there's
there's a certain there's a certain level
of person who's a serious person and there's
a certain level of person who's like living
in Los Angeles and working at Starbucks
and call calling themselves an actor,
who's not really an actor right now or not trying
to be an actor who's not like taking the classes
in their spare time or what I mean like acting
in short films for free because they just want
to they're hungry and they want to get a good
re and and hopefully get a good agent or manager
whoever's going to help him go to the next level
you want to surround yourself with that serious
type of person you don't want a person who's like
kind of half in half out but that's not something
you could be able to discern right away I mean
you meet someone in a party you don't know about
them but you meet them at a party again well I'm
going for network for this thing oh that's great
that's great you're doing that fantastic good
for you I should try to hire him for the thing
whatever it is so we can get him cheap well we
still we still we still get them for cheap do
we always wish we'd find our way sooner I mean
that's 100% I think everyone looks back on what
they could have done or whatever if I actually
gone to USC and gone to film school instead of
going to being a psychology major although I'll
tell you this doing that helped me out quite a
lot in terms of like testing movies like there's a
psychology that goes into an audience there's also
a psychology that goes into filmmakers How can
I calm this person down he's a crazy person he's
literally a crazy person I need to like figure
out how to like crazy talk that person down or
whatever I got to be like the crazy whisperer
or something like that so psychology definitely
help with that look I mean would I have traded
18 years of doing market research for being a
producer sooner in some ways no because I think
it gave me a different perspective a different
perspective that a lot of filmmakers don't have
and I think I see things more sometimes and fault
me or not from a commerce aspect than an art
aspect I see both but I don't think that people
who are artists necessarily see the Commerce and
they need to see the Commerce unfortunately like
they they they are unaware that this thing is
going to need to be sold it's going to need to
be like packaged it's going to need to be a lot of
different things before people actually ever watch
it and then you get a claim and quote unquote
money and the swimming pool and the supermodel
girl or whatever the hell it is you want like
people want all kinds of things you're going
to have to figure out there's there's not just
your vision there is a Commerce of whole thing
and I think that because of what I did I realized
that and I it's part of my DNA so I think that I
bring that to the table that I wouldn't have
before if I hadn't done the job I did before.